the tesla electric semi truck set to
revolutionize trucking as a whole
as of the making of this video it's not
out yet but it's coming soon in 2020
oh oh and they want to use lithium-ion
batteries oh no
alright my swindle sensor is tingling so
let's take a look at the tesla electric
semi how does it measure up
can it truly revolutionize long distance
trucking and make it environmentally
friendly
let's find out alright welcome welcome
welcome
to the to the welcome to the tesla semi
truck
event i hope you like what you see
generally speaking electric vehicles are
fine
they are better than internal combustion
engines but by themselves they will not
be a solution to anything
as in traffic or climate change now the
two main things hindering electric cars
from real mass adoption
are range and price even today in 2021
electric cars are
kind of a niche meaning that only rich
and or environmentally conscious people
will get electric
cars and this is because of the two
aforementioned hindrances
i.e if you want an environmentally
friendly electric car that comes even
near the performance of petrol cars
get ready to be paying out the ass for
it but trucking itself doesn't really
have these problems does it
trucks are big powerful machines able to
carry a lot of battery weight so range
should not be a problem
and pricing should not be a problem
either because logistics companies have
significantly more capital or they can
leverage more loans if they want to than
a private person
oh man so far this sounds pretty
promising did elon musk actually do it
did he finally create something that
isn't just a
worse version of what we already have
did he
alright let's take a look so here we are
on tesla's website where they list the
most important specifications of the
semi truck
we have a acceleration with a full
permissible load up to
60 miles per hours at 20 seconds we have
a 60 miles per hour up a 5
grade we have a 300 to 500 mile range we
have a four independent motors on real
axles as a powertrain
energy consumption fuel savings base
price blah blah blah
the most important thing seems to be
missing weird you know whenever a
company puts out a new electric car the
first question of literally everyone is
okay how far will this thing go with one
battery charge but logistics companies
are after a very different number
one we call load capacity and as i've
mentioned strangely enough it is missing
from the tesla website
but elon why wouldn't you publish the
load capacity that is your money shot
that is the most important thing in
logistics that's the one thing companies
care about
okay you know what i'm going to help out
elon musk and calculate the load
capacity for him
and afterwards he'll be free to use the
numbers in my video and put it on his
website
so first let's do the calculations for
your average combustion engine
semi-truck so trucks have a weight limit
which they cannot exceed
this is 80 000 pounds in the us or 36
tons
the weight of the cargo plus the vehicle
cannot exceed this number
and so your average semi truck weighs 35
000 pounds or 16 tons
this is of course an engine plus trailer
and so the fuel tanks of trucks can hold
around 300 gallons or 1135 liters
one liter of fuel weighs 0.77 kilograms
and so a full tank will weigh 874
kilograms so let's round it up to one
tonne for the sake of simplicity
meaning 16 tons of truck plus one ton of
fuel so with that we use up 17 tons of
our allowance of 36 tons meaning we'll
be able to transport 19
tons of useful cargo alright so let's
see how the tesla semi measures up to
this
and this will be determined by our
concept of today 1 to 20
meaning to get the same result as with
using one kilogram of fossil fuel
you need 20 kilograms of battery this
should also factor in the efficiency
difference between electric and
combustion engines
but this is of course an approximation
so if you want the same results as a
conventional truck with 874 kilos of
fuel
your battery will weigh 17 tons
so a 16 ton truck and a 17 ton battery
is 33
tons meaning that you'll have a load
capacity of
3 tons that's 1 6 that have a regular
truck
and that's why the number is missing
from tesla's website but don't worry
elon musk has already hinted at a
battery capacity jump in the future
he suggested that tesla may be able to
produce better batteries which
could even enable electric planes okay
alright
what's that elon musk promises a 50
increase in energy density
all right let's take a look so if one
kilogram of fossil fuel stores say 20
units of energy then one kilogram of
battery currently holds one unit or one
twentieth
elon musk wants to increase this by 50
to 1.5 units
meaning that you would go up to around
13 kilograms of batteries storing as
much as one kilogram of fuel
this would of course be an improvement
over the 20 units meaning that elon
musk's theoretical future could be maybe
perhaps hyper battery would still weigh
about 11
tons this leaves us with a load capacity
of 9
tons which is less than half of a
regular truck
maybe if they can put together the
battery and if it will be as advertised
at that point and only at that point
will you be able to carry
50 less cargo than a regular truck and
if you come up with a battery that has a
similar energy density to regular fuel
then
fine i guess but then you're going to
have other problems such as what if the
battery catches fire
you know how tesla's sometimes
spontaneously combust imagine this thing
doing it or better yet imagine a tunnel
accident
dying in a chemical inferno would be the
ultimate elon musk
epic bacon 420 way to go out for some
people anyway
so anyway the tesla survived truck
complete failure and it closely follows
the usual elon musk pattern
you know it's like a subway but shittier
it's like a bus but shittier it's like
an airplane but [ __ ] air is like a
high-speed train but shittier it's like
a freight train but shittier
and now we have a semi-truck but
shittier and i feel additionally sorry
for elon really it will be difficult for
him to enter the trucking business since
among trucks gamer lights are pretty
widespread already so it won't be easy
to bamboozle people who are journalists
chef well as you descend the escalator
into the loop station
you see the teslas waiting to whisk you
into a tunnel
43 feet below ground now you might think
all right it's like a subway
but this is more like a highway
underground
and because it's las vegas this is also
a thrill ride
thank you for watching please like and
subscribe and i have a patreon if you
think this content is worth your money
link is in the description and i'll see
you next time